européen est autant de pouvoirs sur
notre quotidien je crois qu'il a résumé
notre discussion
notre quatrième sujet ce soir c'est
quelqu'un de très clair puisque nous
demandions de la clarté c'est stéphane
bern il est très énervé c'est pas de
merde car lundi soir les députés de la
majorité ont de nouveau voté la
suppression de l'exonération fiscale
dont mais difficile le loto du
patrimoine enfin donc il serait sensé
benetti bénéficier pourtant en novembre
dernier le sénat lui avait donné raison
la bataille continue donc et c'est peu
dire que l'animateur est énervé on
écoute en tout cas le résumé de cette
situation assez complexe par jean louis
touraine
écoutez quand même c'est stupide 1
l'état n'était pas capable de faire face
à la rénovation et maintien des
bâtiments historiques est ce qu'il fait
il lança lou tau il lance un auto
récupère de l'argent
enfin pour le patrimoine et en même
temps ils se sucrent il en a vu une
partie alors que c'était sa
responsabilité et il va mettre ça sur
d'autres d'autres disciplines qui sont
de sa responsabilité c'est juste pour
renflouer le budget de l'état c'est
complètement stupide et là alors taxés
puis rembourser alors on imagine ce que
ça peut représenter comme dépenses en
termes administratifs il un p tit ce que
ça représente
taxer puis rembourser alors stéphane
bern a tweeté le patrimoine c'est une
histoire de france et notre identité il
vaut mieux que vos taxes mesquine de
petits comptables et dont on oubliera
les noms avant de les connaître
alors périco légasse et la raison d'état
c'est la macro ni dans toutes ces vertus
on a un président de groupe s'appelle
gilles legendre qui est aux ordres du
plaisir publiques du premier ministre
donc si le groupe est revenue en arrière
sur cette procession qui avait été fait
ses fans bien c'est que l'elysée et
matignon a accepté donc les cocus
comptez-vous j'ai pourtant je sais si
des parties stéphane bern avec de la
bonne foi de la ferveur dans cette
formidable opération
il a totalement raison tour à hennebont
c c'est non mais on sait bien que là
c'est bercy il ya des énarques à bercy
les vrais patrons ce pays qui ont décidé
qu'on allait taxer et ans marthe accès
parce que monsieur alexis colère je me
suis ribadeau dumas on en a décidé ainsi
et qu'on ne t'a jamais contre leur avis
qui était lisse du pouvant saint-antoine
qui a été rénové caroline valentin on
n'a pas besoin de faire des économies
malgré tout est ce qu'il faut est-ce que
patrimoine c'est la priorité
alors attendez le c'est un cas un petit
peu d'abord d'abord je tiens à dire que
stéphane bern est formidable je trouve
qu'il fait le job de manière magistrale
alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans ses
dents au jour d'hui il se passe que il
ya des taxes il ya un loto sportif un
loto du patrimoine sur ses gains de ce
loto qui sont deux d'environ 200
millions d'euros et des taxes qui sont
prélevées les prélève 7 % exactement
mais par ailleurs il compense en fait ce
prélèvement de taxes
est ce que dit donc d'un côté les taxes
ce qu'il d'argent qui lèverait les à la
fondation du patrimoine sont prélevés
sous forme de taxes mais de l'autre le
mystère de la culture redonne sa sous
forme de crédits alloués au patrimoine
s'engage à le faire le problème c'est
que ça fait un double jeu de double
écriture à somme nulle et tenace
attitude sur le fait que c'est
exactement que sept de ces crédits
soient alloués systématiquement d'une
année sur l'autre
donc c'est pas vraiment vraiment
d'argent c'est un problème
un petit peu de technique et budgétaire
et alors sachant qu'en plus les impôts
sont censés financer la fondation pour
le sport donc jeté là dessus stéphane
bern est assez bon parce qu'il dit je
trouve ça très drôle quand il ya des
paris sportifs les textes ne vont pas au
patrimoine
c'est juste que tu as des spams et
effectivement on peut rendre grâce quand
même un mac ronde à voir nommer une
personnalité médiatique que les français
aiment bien à ce poste-là est quelqu'un
qui fait le job de manière magistrale
donc d'avoir redonné quand même de
l'importance au patrimoine ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant maintenant
ensuite sur cette petite broutille
budgétaires je suis assez d'accord avec
ses fans merci maxi grave il faisait
certes et caro jean valentin une
broutille budgétaire a libéré richard
verdi aux fêtes choses compliquées comme
ça chez vous la difficulté c'est
qu'effectivement l'administration
française des finances à savoir donc
bercy se croient investis de garder les
clés d'un trésor qui par ailleurs font
quand même
en gros de toutes manières la france est
trop dépensière de toute manière les
gouvernements manil carnet de chèques
beaucoup trop qu'ils ne le devraient et
donc vous avez à bercy une sorte de
secte d'inspecteur des finances qui
pensent que leur rôle est de couper dès
qu'ils le peuvent
là en l'occurrence ils ont dû penser que
l'opportunité était trop belle
on y va alors que sur d'autres choses ou
peut-être qu'il y aurait des fois
récupérés ils ne le font pas parce que
c'est peut-être plus explosif
après tout c'est à dire il n'a que sa
notoriété médiatique qu'il peut utiliser
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il fait moi je
trouve qu'il aurait été plus simple de
dire dès le départ encore une fois ce
loto là parce qu'il a ce but
patrimoniale il sera exempté des taxes
prévues quitte par contre et ça se
répète au nom de la solidarité justifier
de dire à stéphane bern que s'il reste
de l'argent ça peut arriver quand même
s'il reste de l'argent cet argent devra
être reversés à d'autres oeuvres
je trouve que là on aurait mis tout le
monde en responsabilité je n'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi on n'y arrive pas
en france vous avez choisi telles
oeuvres non mais ça pourrait être les
jeunes sportifs tout ça me paraît au
premier abord c'est pas vrai on
s'aperçoit souvent qu'il reste de
l'argent pour des raisons x ou y adjoint
l'art est chez nous vois faire oui mais
ma des couches gaspacho il aurait plus
responsabilisés l'équipe de stéphane
bern le mail on le 10 ans à l'avant ce
que en fonction des résultats obtenus
on attend d'eux qu'ils n'en reversent
peut-être une partie pour d'autres
oeuvres ou des choses qui sont liés
monuments historiques sans être dans la
pure rénovation du patrimoine je suis
sûr qu'on aurait pu trouver des
solutions intelligentes et simple on
arrive à des engueulades pas très simple
et pas très saine alors à l'antenne on
voit le petit couvent de saint-antoine
et puis normalement la queue du que ces
deux projets qui ont de vraies d'un
passionné n'a rien ne vous choisissez
ces projets ou bien d'autres projets qui
est plus importante
nouveauté bing on va simplement public
amenant le premier important je finance
un stade à côté par exemple pourquoi je
vote pour l'abbaye de sénanque gorn et
ça c'est pour des raisons tout à fait
personnelles très bon choix alors
luhrmann provençal dans toute sa
splendeur
non c'est un petit peu comme la question
tout à l'heure alors évidemment c'est un
autre sujet c'était une belle réforme
systémique à savoir on responsabiliser
les citoyens parce que l'état est dans
une difficulté
la france a un patrimoine local
incroyable sauf qu'évidemment plus on
avance dans le temps plus difficiles
entretenir donc on à responsabiliser les
français à travers ce loto voilà et on
se retrouve avec cette question là qui
est une question paramétrique au fond
oui effectivement à une note de la
bougie il ya une note de la fondation il
ya une note de la fondation jean jaurès
il avait très tôt dit attention il n'y a
pas de ligne dédiée ça va au pot commun
donc forcément ça va pouvoir
éventuellement abondée à peu près tout
bon donc ça effectivement c'est toujours
la même question
ça doit alerter le présent de la
république sur sur voilà il ya toujours
des intentions qui sont perdus temps
très intéressante et on voit dans la
mise en oeuvre à la fin on est sur des
choses qui sont un peu compliqué
d'autant plus que que l'art par les
stéphane bern mais il est entouré ils
ont tous rire c'est mon ancien directeur
de cabinet de
voilà qui est sa responsable qui est une
énarque qui connaît très très bien le
fonctionnement de l'état c'est pas des
c'est pas des oiseaux qui voudra mais
c'est pas des oiseaux qui font n'importe
quoi et qui vont jeter de l'argent un
peu partout serre que voilà on a pas on
n'a pas décidé de voilà donc il ya un
sujet qu'on connaît très bien que vous
avez évoqué c'est que c'est toujours
bercy contre tous les autres ministères
c'est normal c'est comme ça quand vous
allez en réunion interministérielle vous
savez vous avez coltiner bercy donc là
il ya ce sujet là ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il venait magron dans peu de temps
10 on va faire peut-être un geste par
rapport à tout ça on va voir ça sera
mais ça sera un élément important
il paraît qu'il s'énerve déjà temps en
temps à l'elysée dans les briser contre
bercy en dix ans il y en a marre de ces
alors en tout cas romain quelques
conseils allemand il nous dit les gilet
jaune devraient manifester pour sauver
le patrimoine voilà qui devrait
encourager et m'a traitée de manière
séparée gym jupitérien c'est un régime
pénal au pied il des causes de la nuit
ce guide
je cultive toujours voilà je vous
remercie nous nous retrouvons demain 17h
et nous en serons plus sur la fumée
jaune qui devrait sortir ce soir du
bureau de matignon blanche pardon
pressante certifié aux os avoue-t-il
dans mon pote 6 et voilà merci
[Musique]